hello and welcome to introduction and
best practices for google cloud storage
my name is Geoffrey Noer a product
manager for clap for cloud storage and
with me today is Lavina Jain software
engineer with cloud storage today we'll
be walking through you through a brief
introduction including some information
about how to to take advantage of
location types and storage classes then
we'll focus on best practices for two of
our most important to use cases content
serving and compute and analytics and
then finally some words of wisdom on
performance and scaling and how to take
advantage of the performance that cloud
storage has to offer so first of all
what is cloud storage so not to be
confused with file storage or block
storage cloud storage is our object
store and is often by considered by many
to be the native format for storage in
the cloud what we provide is a simple
interface with a consistent API strongly
consistent listings and low latency and
and equivalent speed across all of our
storage classes which makes for a very
smooth experience on the product
reliability is of utmost importance both
from a durability as well as from an
availability standpoint
cost-effectiveness of course as you
don't want storage to be the majority of
your budget and then finally security
because it's of course you want to make
sure that you can control who has access
to your data and to make sure that that
your data is always encrypted at rest
and in transit the foundation in many
respects of cloud storage is a high
performance high quality network that
Google built for its own purposes
initially for all of the consumer
properties that you are used to using
and so this involves multiple undersea
cable investments large numbers of
points of presence across the planet and
as well as a substantial number of cloud
regions and this allows you to really
pick a location that makes sense for
your data with the knowledge that you
can distribute your content to any any
part of the globe that you may need to
the three primary use cases
we see our content storage and delivery
so for example National Geographic uses
cloud storage for for its content
serving purposes and this you know this
is ideal because of low latency and and
the ability to take advantage of all of
those edge caches to push content across
the globe we have a lot of use for
compute analytics and machine learning
so this is more the high performance
inside the cloud
use of storage here customers like the
Broad Institute doing high-performance
genomics sequencing analysis or or for
that matter
Twitter analyzed doing analytics on on
the the overall corpus of tweets are
both examples of customers using us for
that sort of purpose and here you know
you can the sky's the limit you can
scale up to terabits per second of
throughput from a cloud storage bucket
to make those workloads screen and then
finally we have backup and Antle it and
backup and archiving use cases where
it's really more about storing the data
long-term and so regulatory compliance
tools like bucket lock that allow you to
to guarantee that data will not be
deleted for a specified length of time
those sorts of facilities really help
the use case for for for those needs so
let's turn first to storage classes to
go a little bit deeper into his cloud
storage because it's really about the
locations that you choose and then the
storage classes that determine you know
your frequency of access and and
ultimately the price point that you pay
so the first stage in in storing data is
actually to decide what kind of a
location type you want to use regions
multi regions in dual regions are all
available to you with a number of
different specific location choices
within each so regions are the most
basic choice they allow you to have all
of your data in one specific region so
for example you might choose US central
one or you might choose Europe Europe
west one and once you've chosen that
specific location for your bucket all of
your data will be stored there
so the
advantages you can then run your VMs or
others to cloud services and have those
have that compute and storage be
co-located for the best possible
performance and regions also provide a
very attractive price point now if you
want geo redundancy for a higher
availability protecting you against
particular regional outages then what
you can do is you can choose either a
dual region or a multi region dual
regions are more like regions in that
you know exactly where your data is
located and namely they'll be located in
the two specific regions that are part
of that dual region and so again for for
analytics and other workloads that are
high-performance dual regions are
usually the right choice and then multi
regions on the other hand you just know
that your data is geo redundant and
stored somewhere within a continent and
this is an ideal choice for content
serving so how do we place the data so
in a region which is the the yellow
squares if you chose region B as your
region all of your data will be placed
in region B so that's the most
straightforward example um in blue is
the dual region and with a dual region
it's one copy in one region one copy and
the other so your data is redundant
across those two specific regions and
then with multi regions every object
might be replicated differently and so
for your entire bucket you're likely to
have data distributed across the
continent and if you're serving to the
to the internet any additional latency
is not really a consideration because of
the internet Layton sees that it will be
added to it so once you've picked a
particular type of location type the
next choice has to do with your default
storage class and in reality you can
have objects that are in all of your
storage classes so you can start out in
standard and then also have also have
colder data that is in near line cold
line or archive so what you know what is
the difference between the storage
classes that really comes down to a
trade-off between price and frequency of
access and length of storage and so if
we look at the best
practices this is where that becomes
clear but if you're going to retain data
for for example more than a year and
only access it once a year or two that
would up be an ideal use case for the
archive storage class and in fact much
of the data there is intended never to
be read maybe it would only be read if
there's a regulatory compliance issue
that needs to be looked into four years
after some logs are written for example
but on the other hand maybe you're doing
a really really frequently accessed
analytics workload where you're you're
turning through a very large amount of
data quickly maybe your data is only
living for a few days but other other
other objects are staying around for
longer
that's where standard comes into play
and then of course near line cold line
are in the middle so near line is
usually for once once a quarter and
unless them and retained for at least
one month
and whereas cold line is at least
retained for at least three months and
you don't want to access it only you
know a few times a year so you can use
this as a good benchmark but so then
what do you do well the this is where
you take advantage of object lifecycle
management and we provide all of the
utilities to inside the product to be
able to automatically migrate your data
from standard down to near line to cold
line to archive and you can do that
based on the age of the objects which is
usually very applicable to workloads
because cold data is usually
infrequently accessed
you can also manually moved at
particular data sets with or with a
storage rewrite whether to change the
storage classes so no matter how you
approach it you can use the the multiple
storage classes as a way of optimizing
your total cost of ownership so that
your cold data is charged the least and
your hot data the most as you would as
you would hope for security is critical
and we provide a good amount of
flexibility in the product so one thing
that you'd never need to worry about is
whether your data is encrypted so your
data is always encrypted at rest and in
transit and that's not even an option
so some other services just make it you
know you have you have to be a little
bit more careful about that with us it's
always encrypted but the default is that
the keys for the encryption are actually
stored in Google and managed by Google
and then depending on your your level of
paranoia and desire for control over
over the encryption you can take more
and more control first by still keeping
the the keys inside the key management
service inside Google Cloud but where
you manage the key rotations and
relocations so there it's that's kind of
a best of both worlds in some respects
and then if you want full of complete
control you can actually supply the keys
with every access and have a key server
running on premises outside of Google
Cloud in which case Google really
literally could not access your data
even if even if you ask Google to with
the other two where where Google does
have access to the keys all of any
accesses are fully logged and we never
look at data unless there is a support
case or other legitimate reason where
where we do need to go in and access the
data and again that would all be fully
logged and transparent so we take we
take security and privacy both extremely
seriously
so with that basic introduction to the
framework of location types and storage
classes and security let's see how those
choices apply to the first of our two
use cases that we're going to discuss
today which is content serving so there
are really four primary considerations
with with with content serving some
people decide to do direct serving
others use the Google cloud CDN product
as a complement to to cloud storage
others combine cloud storage with a
custom front-end which also might be
used with cloud CDN and then finally
there's the opportunity to use
independent CDNs outside of Google to
combine with cloud storage to to
actually stream or serve the data from
those independent third parties so for
direct serving this is in many respects
the easiest approach it's fully in
with the product there's nothing more
that you need to do you can do this just
straight out of the the cloud storage
offering and um here there's some real
advantages in that we automatically use
the premium Google Network for
distribution and as and take advantage
of the the edge caching if you turn it
on with cache control headers so go
ahead and turn the cache control headers
on and that will allow repeated accesses
to have significantly lower latency then
of course the first cold access would
have had so it's it's it's in many ways
a built-in content distribution network
in terms of the the location type we
were typically advise using multi
regions because this provides you with
the highest possible availability and
and basically continent based serving so
and and that actually can't even be
serving out of for example a u.s. multi
region to the globe or you might copy
you might actually have different
multi-region buckets in different
continents to serve those populations it
really depends on your use case and how
how your content is is oriented what
cloud CDN does is it means that all of
your reads don't go back and hit the
cloud storage service only the cold the
cold misses where you haven't recently
accessed that storage doesn't go back to
cloud storage so you won't have any any
egress charges from cloud storage those
will all get handled by cloud CDN
instead it also provides you with custom
domains with SSL some more flexibility
on the URLs for access and and like but
of course the number one reason is to
access the differentiated pricing that's
available through cloud CDN custom front
ends are a way that you can put have an
intermediary service between cloud
storage and the customer this can be a
popular for example if you want to have
an authorization stage before access or
if you need to dynamically transform the
data in some way before it streams out
from the from the date from the from the
service so here it depends on
whether you would want you might want to
use a region you might want to use a
dual region to co-locate the storage
with your with your custom front-end
depending on how much disaster recovery
and business continuity you want to
build into the model the dual region
would be the better choice for high
availability but if your service doesn't
require that a region would be
sufficient and then um you can still
combine this with cloud CDN to take
advantage of the caching and the other
advantages that I just talked about if
you're using an independent third party
CDN this is again an example where using
a region or a dual region makes more
sense than a multi region and this is
because the whole purpose of using an
independent CDN is to have an origin
shield between the two that means the
only cold content hits will end up going
back to Google but you want those to be
hitting Google the Google region that is
in close proximity to where the
independent CDN has their set up so if
they're located very close to Iowa for
example you might in a data center near
there you might want to use US central
one which is is the google region that
is located in that same state so so
trying to have close proximity and low
latency between the scene independent
CDN and Google is really the first is
the first matter of importance for the
best performance with an independent CDN
so with that I'd like to turn the
presentation over to Lavinia Jane who
will take it from here
thanks Jeff so I'll talk about how to
pick the right location time for compute
and analytics workloads and then share
some tips on performance and scalability
compute and analytics pipelines have
several types of data and your choice of
location type really depends on the type
of data first you have the source data
this is data that is persistent and that
you need to load up right when you start
your pipeline what is really important
here is very high throughput so you
would want to co-locate your compute
with storage and using a region or a
dual region location make sense the
second type of data is intermediate data
this is data that is produced by one
stage of your pipeline and consumed by
another stage now if this data is
persistent then using cloud storage you
make sense and the same recommendations
of collocating compute with storage and
using a region or a dual region location
apply however many times this data is
very short-lived and users need high
throughput and low latency in that case
actually cloud storage is not our the
best product that you could use for this
data consider using local SSD or
persistent disk for example the third
type of data is side inputs and staging
data this data is typically read only
once per welcome so choice of location
type doesn't really matter much here
because cloud storage does a lot of
caching so even if the first read is
removed and slow the success of reads
will be fast and finally you have final
outputs that your pipeline produces the
choice of location type and storage
class for this data really depends on
what you plan to do with the data for
example if your pipeline is producing
processed images to be served to
Internet users then really the
recommendations that you have shared
earlier about content serving workloads
apply or if these final outputs are fed
into another pipeline then it really
acts our source data and the
recommendations that I shared earlier
about songs data apply so before moving
on I want to give a quick shout-out to
cloud data proc service there has been a
lot of interest in moving Hadoop
workloads into cloud and cloud data proc
service lets you do exactly that
it is a managed Hadoop service that can
bring up new clusters really fast
there's also a connector for cloud
storage that lets you read your data
from cloud storage directly without
having to first copy it into HDFS there
are a few gotchas to be aware of here
first one is that cloud storage is not a
file system we do not have directory
semantics so you have to get around that
by eliminating any
dependencies on atomic directory
operations for example you could upload
your data temporarily in a temporary
directory and then when the data set is
complete rename the directory or you
could load directly into the final
directory but when you are done with
data write a sentinel file that says hey
I'm done with data secondly a cloud
storage our latency is typically higher
compared to HDFS especially for small
objects so you could get around that by
parallelizing small operations or using
larger object sizes and third as I
mentioned before for temporary data
consider using local SSD now let's talk
about performance and scaling so first
let's understand the general performance
characteristics of object storage one of
the things to remember here is that
latency for small objects could be
relatively high at 95th percentile a one
byte read could take about 100
milliseconds and the same applies for
write as well the strengths of cloud
storage are really horizontal
scalability and single stream throughput
so for a large enough object you should
be able to get about 800 megabits per
second for V and 400 megabits per second
for writes what this means is you would
want to favor large object sizes and
avoid unnecessary sharding now even if
you are able to pack most of your data
into large objects you may still have
those internal segments for structured
data for example that typically tend to
be smaller in size see if you can tune
those up to be a bit larger at least 2
megabytes is a recommended size larger
is of course better and then if you have
to use small object sizes then
parallelize your requests to get around
the inherent latency of the system now
let's talk about how to get the best
performance out of your rights there are
three different write strategies that
you can choose from the simplest one is
called non resume
upload where you can upload your entire
object using a single request the second
one is called presumable upload where
you first send a request to start a
resumable upload session and then send
subsequent requests to upload data using
the same session ID now if one of the
upload requests fail then you can query
the server to find the last offset that
it could successfully commit and then
resume writing from that offset the
third approach is called parallel upload
where you split your object into
multiple parts upload those parts in
parallel and then compose compose is
mostly a metadata only operation and
does not involve rewriting bytes I say
mostly because it does cause data
deletion and then depending on certain
options that you pick it may result in
rewriting data so be careful with the
options that you take there so the
recommendation here is to use non
resumable upload by default the bar to
switch over to start using resumable
upload or parallel upload is really high
that's because resumable upload has a
drawback that uploading every single
object takes a minimum of two requests
now if the first request to start the
session takes about 100 milliseconds
that could be a really large part of
your total upload time for small objects
so the rule of thumb here is to multiply
your expected throughput by 30 seconds
and that gives you the cutoff in terms
of object sizes when it makes sense to
switch over to using presumable upload
to give you some concrete numbers if you
have clients uploading using cable at 4
Mbps upload speed then the cutoff object
size is 15 megabytes or if you have
clients over vm getting a full 400 Mbps
upload speed then you shouldn't really
have to use a resumable upload unless
you have objects as large as one and
half gigabytes or larger the power to
switch to parallel upload is even higher
you should need it unless you're
uploading using a VM
and need more than 400 megabits per
second I do want to call out a gotcha
here that really a compose really makes
sense within standard storage class only
because it could are trigger or Li
deletions lastly I want to talk about
scaling and hotspot in cloud storage
generally scales really well and you
don't have to worry about object counts
and object sizes so there's one case
where we have seen users run into some
scaling bottlenecks and that's localized
hot spotting to explain this let me
first explain what happens under the
hood and then go over recommendations on
how to get around it cloud storage using
a she used as a sharding strategy called
range based shouting so we stole your
objects across multiple servers and the
way we distribute your objects to
servers is by splitting the object name
space into ranges in this example here
any objects that begin with the letter
between e and g will go into the first
sharp objects beginning with the letter
between G and s will go into the second
shop and so on what this allows us to do
is provide consistent listing so
consider use a request to list all
objects that start with T slash this
request will be routed to the third
shard and looking up this one shot is
enough to find all objects starting with
T now consider an alternate charting
strategy which is called hash based
sharding here the shards are assigned to
servers based on the hash of the object
name this distributes the objects all
over the place but the same listing
operation would now have to look up
every single shot both yet if one of the
shots is slow then the latency of the
entire list operation goes up even more
scenario is imagine what happens if one
of the shard fails then we could either
return in complete results or fail the
entire list operation so hash Bay's
sharding doesn't really scale well when
we have to provide consistent listing
hence we chose to go with range based
now one of the shots could get very hot
and we handled that by doing auto
scaling so we detect hot shots and split
them up so I get want to give you a
sense of when does this behavior really
kick in so you can you can easily do up
to thousand object rights for second and
5,000 object treats for second before
really running into this scenario also
typically we try to detect hot shots
ahead of time and split them out so you
don't notice anything but you can expect
a delay of up to 20 minutes the key
thing to making this work really well is
really to distribute the load evenly
across key ranges for majority cases
auto-scaling provides the scalability
that you need without any other
considerations but there is one pattern
that trips this up and that is
sequential access so let's talk about
are some of the object naming patterns
that can cause sequential access the
first one is using a your month in day
format the second is generating order
numbers or user IDs using monotonically
increasing or sequential numbers and the
third one is using a timestamp so you
can get around it by choosing alternate
or object naming schemes for example you
can pick a part of your object name that
is more variable and bring it up front
log type in this example so if you are
accessing different kinds of logs on a
single day those accesses would be
distributed over multiple shots don't
use a sequential number if you don't
have to you could use a UUID instead and
the third approach is to hash the object
name or part of the object name and then
prefix the object name with the hash the
drawback of this approach is that you
cannot do in order listing so if you
care about in order listing then you
could map the hash to a fixed number 10
for example and then to list an order
you could do a 10 P lookup and merge the
results and finally I want to add that
you don't always have
to change the object naming scheme in
case of bulk operations for example you
could simply make sure that all your
accesses are distributed randomly and
evenly so to summarize we talked about
some common use cases of cloud storage
shared some best practices on how to
pick the right storage class and
location time and finally shared some
tips on how to get the best performance
and scalability out of cloud storage
thank you